after a journey of some 15,000
kilometers this will be tuned Chang
fires home for the next couple of days
and first we were in a big hotel but I
didn't want to stay there I want a more
authentic experience of how things are
here on campus Chung Chen far is
accompanying his granddaughter for the
start of her studies he's here together
with her mother who's off running
last-minute errands the start of
semester means hotels near the
university are often fully booked to
deal with the visitor numbers for the
past few years the University of Tintin
in northern China has been pitching
tents as an alternative and free
accommodation parents want to be there
when their children enroll of course the
students can actually take care of
everything on their own they don't need
their parents support but parents want
to be there they're happy to be able to
be part of their children's first steps
on campus soon Cheng hua is being picked
up by his granddaughter for a quick tour
of the campus
some cusine is taking mathematics she's
part of China's one-child generation
like other only children she's the sole
focus of attention for the adults in the
family my mother and grandfather are
coming along because they want to get an
impression of the surroundings of my
fellow students and my teachers but that
doesn't mean that they don't trust me
they know I can take care of things by
myself more parents and grandparents
turn up at the gym hall altogether the
university has put up 800 tents at the
moment not all of them are occupied but
some hopes that more parents will come
[Music]
more people that are here the merrier it
is we Chinese love being in big groups
it's really nice so my song is getting
ready for his first night on campus the
prospect it seems is almost as exciting
as it is for his granddaughter